Tomorrow, in a very real sense, your life,...
...the life you author from scratch on your own, begins.
How will you use your gifts?
What choices will you make?
Will inertia be your guide or will you follow your passions?
Will you follow dogma or will you be original?
Will you choose a life of ease or a life of service and adventure?
Will you wilt under criticism or will you follow your convictions?
Will you bluff it out when you're wrong or will you apologize?
Will you guard your heart against rejection or will you act when you fall in love?
Will you play it safe or will you be a little bit swashbuckling?
When it's tough, will you give up or will you be relentless?
Will you be a cynic or will you be a builder?
Will you be clever at the expense of others or will you be kind?
I will hazard a prediction.
When you are 80 years old and in a quiet moment of reflection,...
...narrating for only yourself,...
...the most personal version of your life story,...
...the telling that will be most compact and meaningful,...
...will be the series of choices you have made.
In the end, we are our choices.
Build yourself a great story.
Thank you and good luck.